All right, Crawley here again for our final chapter. Because PA policies do not require a medical examination, the entire contract rests entirely on the principle of utmost good faith.
The application form is everything. The insurance company relies blindly on the information your client provides. If a client conceals a pre-existing medical condition or a dangerous hobby, the policy is rendered null and void.
You must also establish the principle of insurable interest. If someone is insuring another person, they must have a pecuniary interest, meaning they would suffer a direct financial loss if the assured gets injured or dies.
This is usually limited to family members, business partners, or creditors. Interestingly, PA premiums are not priced based on age.
Instead, the risk is driven by what your client does for a living. Underwriters divide these risks into five occupational classes.
Class 1: White-collar workers with indoor or travel duties like accountants, bankers, and teachers.
Class 2: White-collar workers with limited exposure like doctors, engineers, and land surveyors.
Class 3: Skilled workers with moderate exposure like mechanics, plumbers, and factory workers.
Class 4: Industrial workers using heavy machinery like construction workers, firemen, and truck drivers.
Class 5: The special risk category. This includes airplane crews, miners, professional athletes, and explosive factory workers.
Accurately classifying your client's daily hazards ensures their policy responds when they need it most. Protect their livelihoods. Honor their trust.